do you ever feel like a fire breathing
dragon after eating spicy food like your
throat is burning and you're about to
Exhale a hot column of flames no just me
makes me wonder how dragons could
breathe fire in the first place there
are a lot of ideas how they might but my
favorite is based on the real life
abilities of the Bombadier Beetle this
Beetle has one amazing defense mechanism
to protect itself from predators if
threatened it mixes a combination of
hydrogen peroxide and hydroquinones
inside special Chambers in its body
creating a super heated chemical re
action that elevates to near boiling
then this deadly mixture is explosively
sprayed on the Beatles attacker so maybe
that's how dragons did it we may never
solve the mystery of fire breathing in
Dragon lore unless nature reveals it in
real animals between you and me I
wouldn't want to stick my head your a
dragon's mouth to find out